Let's now get into the thick of it, as we
might be calling it.
We are going to now look very, very closely.
And I'm going to put it up on the screen,
because I think that this we're at a point
where this is really the only way to do it.
We are going we are going to look at what
we know and what we are waiting on when it
comes to this election.
As I said, currently, we are looking at numbers
of Joe Biden, 238.
And in fact, I think I might might even have
a better view of this for, you know, I don't
not necessarily.
Let me actually see if I can.
There we go.
I think that's going to be better for us.
Perfect.
Right now, officially, the count is two thirty
eight for Joe Biden to 13 for Donald Trump.
Now, as a reminder in the map I had for you
guys yesterday, I did not believe that Joe
Biden was going to win Florida.
I did not believe that Joe Biden was going
to win Georgia.
I did not believe Joe Biden was going to win
Ohio.
And in fact, I even had Arizona for Donald
Trump.
So relative to my map from yesterday, looking
only at things that have been called, Joe
Biden is actually doing better than I had.
Everything that has been called has been called,
as I predicted, other than Arizona, which
I had for Trump and has gone to Joe Biden.
Now, the areas of concern, Joe Biden right
now is 32 electoral votes shy of the 270 that
he needs.
Georgia has not yet been called, but I never
believed Georgia was going to go for Biden.
I believe it will eventually go for Donald
Trump.
North Carolina is our first trouble spot.
I believed Caroline, North Carolina would
go Biden right now with 94 percent reporting,
Donald Trump is ahead by one point for now.
If you were on my live stream late last night,
you might notice that these numbers are identical
to the ones that we had last night.
We don't exactly know what's going on in North
Carolina.
Different states are starting to count absentee
ballots in different ways on different cycles.
But the numbers have not moved in North Carolina.
There is certainly the expectation that there
are some strong Biden areas left to be counted,
but we do not know.
Now, I will get to the math implications momentarily.
Pennsylvania is an extremely important state
for us to look at because Pennsylvania is
now plus 10 for Donald Trump.
But you will notice not even two thirds of
the votes have been counted.
And this is where I want to do a deep dove
with you guys before.
And I hope that this is not I hope this isn't
boring to people.
I think this is actually really important
to do.
Pennsylvania is of massive importance to Joe
Biden.
Why Pennsylvania is worth 20 electoral votes.
If Biden gets them, it puts him at two fifty
eight, meaning he needs only 12 more, 12 more,
meaning that Wisconsin and Nevada would do
it or Michigan would do it, and certainly
North Carolina would as well.
Why are these numbers so slow in Pennsylvania?
Because I told you they would be.
Pennsylvania doesn't start counting mail in
ballots until all voting has stopped.
And if we go and look at The New York Times
and zoom in to Pennsylvania, this is where
the devil is really in the details.
If you look at, for example, Philadelphia
County, which contains the city of Philadelphia.
You see that only about half the votes have
been counted there, Joe Biden continues to
lead basically three to one.
It's about 75, 25 even better, actually, in
Philadelphia County for Joe Biden.
Only half of the votes have been counted.
That alone, if you do just some very, very
basic math, is potentially a hundreds of thousands
of vote advantage for Joe Biden.
The numbers there could close half of the
gap that currently exists.
You then look at Pittsburgh.
Pittsburgh, which has counted 70 percent,
Joe Biden is up by nine there, that could
potentially close the gap again by 70000 votes.
Theoretically, Allentown has now gone towards
Donald Trump by a little bit.
But there is a real reason to think that the
outstanding mail in ballots in Allentown,
in the Allentown area, which is Lehigh County,
could be very helpful to Joe Biden.
So when we look at the general number and
this is not me blowing smoke, it's just an
assessment of what we know and what we expect.
When you look at the numbers in Pennsylvania
and you see, wow, 64 percent reporting, Trump
is up 10.
That seems impossible.
But then as you realize how much there is
left to count and you realize that a lot of
those small rural Trump counties are at 100
percent reporting and a lot of these dense
Democratic parts are at 50, 60, 70 percent.
With Biden's margin being huge.
All we can do is count the ballots.
We'll know eventually the results we will
know.
So let's wait on that.
A few other spots to look at Wisconsin.
Wisconsin has now flipped in favor of Joe
Biden.
All of last night.
Wisconsin was red, as they were at 10, 15,
20, 25, 30, even close to 50 percent reporting
Wisconsin was in the Donald Trump column.
And those of us who knew about the Red Mirage
scenario and understood how Wisconsin counts,
we expected it would become close.
When I went to bed, it was red.
When I woke up, it was blue.
It has not yet been called.
It is a small margin.
As of this moment.
Joe Biden is up twenty one thousand votes
in Wisconsin.
The reports from people who know Wisconsin.
Remember, we want to be careful and precise.
The reports from folks who know Wisconsin
are that the areas left to count with mail
in ballots are Democratic leaning areas.
If I were looking at this, my expectation
would be Biden ultimately is going to get
Wisconsin and then lastly, Michigan.
Michigan also 18000 votes right now separating
the two candidates with Joe Biden ahead.
We were seeing panic yesterday, but we were
also hearing from Michigan experts who said,
look at what's in and look at what's outstanding.
This is going to trend towards Joe Biden.
And it has gone indeed now slightly for Joe
Biden.
Now, by the time you listen to this, maybe
Joe Biden will have one.
There's the idea Michigan will be called today
or tomorrow.
Maybe Donald Trump will have taken over.
And then lastly, Nevada.
Nevada has 67 percent reporting.
It's worth six electoral votes.
Joe Biden slightly ahead and then it remains
with North Carolina.
We have that same lead of one point four as
of right now for Donald Trump and questions
about what is outstanding there.
So when we go to the map and we start looking
at scenarios again, even though Georgia has
not been called for Trump, I believe he gets
it.
Let's now look at this scenario.
And also Alaska has not been called for Trump,
but I believe he gets it.
That would put us at 238 to 232 in favor of
Joe Biden.
OK, so what now?
What now is and let me even adjust this so
that we can get I think I want I want the
best.
We don't usually do it this way, but it's
just so important that I do it because we
are looking at these election results live.
I want to have everything on screen for you.
We have a situation where let's imagine for
a second that North Carolina stays with Trump.
OK, that wouldn't be good.
But I want everybody to understand that if
Trump gets North Carolina and even gets Pennsylvania.
If Joe Biden can just hold his leads in Nevada,
Wisconsin and Michigan, he wins, and if he
were to get the Nebraska 2nd District, that
would be 271 Biden, 267 Trump.
And I'll even change these to say Biden Trump.
I am not trying to give you unrealistic scenarios.
I am merely telling you Biden has a path without
Pennsylvania and without North Carolina.
If he were to get not North Carolina, but
Pennsylvania, all of a sudden you can take
Nevada off the table and Biden still wins.
You can even take you can't take Michigan
off the table.
And that's scenario.
Well, you could take Michigan off the table.
If Biden gets Nevada or if he gets Michigan,
you could take Wisconsin and Nevada off the
table and Biden still wins.
So my point here to you is what as we look
at these numbers, my point is.
This was never going to be the blowout that
538 said it would.
This is why my map was very conservative all
along when I was telling people, imagine that
your state is 50/50.
And people would email me saying, David, you're
gaslighting people.
You're making people think it's closer than
it is so that they vote no.
I'm saying we don't really know how close
some of these states are with absentee ballots
and all of these potential factors.
All we know is we have the opportunity to
vote and we should.
And now, indeed, it is going to be much closer
to my map than anything we got from any of
these modelers.
So we have to just go through the process
and understand Biden can win without Pennsylvania
or North Carolina.
If he holds his leads in Nevada, Michigan
and Wisconsin, he doesn't actually need North
Carolina or Pennsylvania.
If Biden gets North Carolina or Pennsylvania,
Pennsylvania being more likely, those results
start to look significantly better.
Other things that I wanted to look at, I guess
the only other thing to look at here would
be, um, in terms of the presidency, just looking
at the popular vote is one thing I would look
at.
The popular vote right now is almost sixty
nine million votes for Joseph Biden Jr. and
more than 66 million votes for Donald Trump.
So, again, Joe Biden, by the time it's done,
will have easily won the popular vote record
vote, by the way, for Donald Trump added about
three million votes.
And we're going to talk about that a little
bit later.
That is really, really important.
But that is where we are right now.
So is it time to panic?
It's definitely time for concern.
But Joe Biden has two completely separate
paths to victory, one which includes Pennsylvania
and or North Carolina, less likely North Carolina,
and one which doesn't require either of them,
which goes through Wisconsin, Michigan and
Nevada.
Count every ballot.
Don't get ahead of ourselves.
We will be here with you.
Let me know your thoughts.
I'm on Twitter at
David Pakman